では よろしくお願いします
えーと どこまで進めましたっけ
で この経典ではこのチョンダという大長老ですね
大阿羅漢ですから まあ自分一人でいると考えた考え方ですね
で その考え方何なのかというと
この何て言ってもその意見というか
邪見というかね 持たない状態って何なのかって
これは一般的なね 俗人にはこれわからないポイントなんですよ
で 人間っていうのは必ずもある見方で物事を見たり聞いたり考えたりするんですよ
見方がなしに何も成り立ちません
いつでも頭の中で比べるための尺度というものがあるんですよ
で 例えば何か食べ物をあげて
これはどうでしょうかと
あ おいしいですよと言われた時も
自分の頭の中である尺度があるんですよ
その尺度で測ってみて決めるんですね
それで 各人が自分で尺度を持っていて
物事について判断したり考えたりするんだから
例えば本を書いたっても
本を書いた人は自分の尺度を持ってるんですよ
それで物事を測ってみて整理して世に出すんですよ
これで真理なのかと それがありのままの事実なのかとという点から見ると
これはちょっと違うんじゃないかなと
例えば日本にいる我々は
海苔っていうのはとても美味しい食べ物だと
当たり前ではないかというふうな尺度を持っていて
でも 海の植物を全然全くも食べない
食べたこともない人に聞いたら違う意見出すんですよ
で それでどちらが正しいかと
しかし その人に聞けば
じゃああなた推薦する一番美味しい野菜って何なのかというと
まあ別なもの これが一番美味しいと言ったりする
それを食べる日本にいる人々は
いや これはそんなに美味しくないよというふうに言うかもしれません
ですから どちらが正しいかと
どちらが真理を語っているのかと
という問題が出てきますよ
私はあるインドの大教授に
あの 海苔を食べてくださいと
まあ厳密な菜食主義者でしたからね
海苔も断るんですよ 海苔も嫌ですと
で 徹底的になんで海苔が嫌ですかと
これはもう純粋な あの
何て言いますか この菜食主義の
まあ食べ物ですよと 何の心配もなく食べられますと
他の食べ物っていうのはちょっと怪しいんだと
何とかの形で日本の料理っていうのは
そういう動物のものを入れちゃいますと
全部 で お出汁やらいろいろ取ったりするんだからね
だからこれがそういう問題はないと
いろいろ言ったんですけど
あまりにも私はしつこく言うんだから
彼がたった一言葉 「魚の匂いがする」
で それで私がある尺度を持っていて
その教授がある尺度を持っていて
だからその方については魚の匂いがするものを食べないということで
匂いさえも嫌と そこでまた我々には別な尺度で考えることもできます
本当に海苔は魚の匂いがするかと
皆様に聞けば笑っちゃうでしょ
海苔なに魚の匂いするっていうのはどういうことかと
実際 魚の匂いがするんですよ
その先生の立場から見ると
私はあまりもう尺度を取らんで考えたところで
魚の匂いって何なのかと
やっぱり自分も初めて海に行った時は
生まれて初めて 魚の匂いがしたんです
海そのものが かなり結構匂いなんですよ
海っていうのはそれほど小さくはないんだからね
あれ？あれは海の匂いじゃないかなと
だから海の植物は海の匂いを持っている
魚にも まあそれなりに似ている匂いはあります
体に  そういうことで まあこれそれどちらがでしょうかね
海に匂いがあるんだのと言ったら
これまた反対する人いるでしょ
海は結構匂いますよというと
何言うんでしょうかという人もいるし
だからどちらが正しいかっていうね
問題が出てる とにかく
尺度 が人間にはあります
これが仏教は厄介な問題として見ているんですよ
では 我々には何一つも考えられますか？尺度置いといて
フリーで 何か考えられますか？何一つも考えることはできないんですよ
フリーで 何一つも見ることもできないんですよ
何一つも聞くこともできないんです
いつでも尺度が割り込むんですよ
何か触ってみたっても
すぐ尺度がそちらに割り込むんですよ
私たちの生き方っていうのは
完全にそうやってこの尺度というものでもう絡み合って生きているんですね
こちらに来る前 事務所でいろいろやったりしたんですけど
全て尺度の話なんですよ
お釈迦さんの後輩の意はどうでしょうか
ああ これはいいですねとか
これが尺度の考え方なんですよ
これぐらい値段ってどうです
まあまあ いいんじゃないかなとか
それ尺度なんですよ で
優子さんが何か文章をレイアウトして印刷して
これどうですか ああ これでいいんじゃないんですかと
そこでもしそれ私の尺度で比べたら
尺度に合わなかったらもうちょっと何とかならないかと言うし
そういう風に何をしても全てそのその人間の間でみんな持ってる尺度で合わせていることなんですよ
これがどうしようもないかっていうことでもないし
これ自体 尺度論自体がかなり人間考えなくちゃいけない人間の問題なんですよ
それで世の中でこの尺度について
この視野というかね いい視野持ちなさいとかね
広い視野を持ちなさいとかね
どうでもいいんですよ
視野だからね 尺度だから
それで噛み合わなくなるんですよ
例えば人間はみんな平等だという尺度を持ってる人と
中国人は世界一偉いと尺度を持ってる人と喋れますかね
ぶつかるんですよ 同じ尺度っていうのは持てるかという問題もありますよ
二人がいて やっぱり人間みんな平等だと
二人ともやっぱり人間みんな平等だと言っても
本当に同じですかと という問題もありますよ
だから このただ言葉に似ていたんだからといってね
人間みんな兄弟だとか
そっちいろんな人言ってるでしょうに
でもそれで似ている 同じアイデアやと考え方似ているんだとということにはならないんですよ
なぜならば そのその人はその尺度を作った
また原因があるんですよ
また情報があるんです
その人に その人がある思考パターンがあって
その結論として尺度を作ってるんですよ
だから西洋人が人間みんな兄弟だということと
インド人が人間みんな兄弟だということっていうのは似ていないと思いますけどね
それでこのすごいこの尺度という問題っていうのはかなり大変な問題なんです
我々の生き方そのもの
完全に尺度というものから成り立っているんですね
この仏教でディッティディッティというのはそういうものなんですよ
ディッティで出来上がっているんです
ディッティというのはビューポイントというものであって
視野ということなんですよ
見やら邪見やらあれやこれやとかね
専門用語使った方が便利かもしれませんだけど
そうすると理解しなくても済みますからね
専門用語ばっかり並び替えればね
で 残念なことにこれ視野ということなんですよ
意味は もっと即物即的な日本語で言えば尺度ですよ
だからご飯がおいしいかないかというために
味噌汁の味がどうでしょうかと
もうちょっと薄めた方がいいか
あるいはもっと味噌を入れればいいかということを判断するためにも
やっぱり尺度が必要なんですよ
一歩一歩歩く時でも我々は尺度を使ってるんですよ
これで目を開けたものを見たで
見たところで まあ尺度で見ているんです
これがなんで仏教それは大問題に
これは代々ないんですよ
これはもう 何ですかね
これはもう言えば唯一な問題ですよ
これが存在に関わる問題というふうに見ているんです
これしょうがないではないかというのは俗人の考え方で
人間そうだからと これは逃げ腰
勇気のある人の態度じゃないんです
これはしょうがないではなくて
しょうががありますよ
これ問題ですよ で なんで人間悩んでいるんですか？なんで我々は互いに仲が悪いんですかと
なんで我々は喧嘩するんですか？なんで我々は戦争するんですかと
なんで生きる上で苦労しているんですかね
尺度でしょう なんで子供
自分が産んだ子供なのに
子育てでいろんなトラブルが起きるんですかね
これ尺度の問題ですよ
子供は一つを言うし 母親がまた別なことを言うし
これトラブっちゃうんですね
あるいは子供はなんとか一生懸命言ってるんですけど
母親は全然それ理解しない
別なものだと勘違いしたりする
それ なんで母親の心に届かなかったと
子供の言ってることはっていうのは
母には母の尺度があったんだからなんです
それにははめなかったんですね
だから周波数が変わってるんだから
いくらこちらで放送しても受信できないということなんですね
だから私の生き方 生きるということは
完全に尺度を持って生きることで考えて生きていることでしょうし
だからこれで全ての生命とのぶつかり合いが生まれます
それだけじゃないんですよ
まるっきり もう何の生命とも関係なく一人でいるぞと思っても
この人が見るもの聞くものっていうのは
それでも風の音を聞いても尺度で聞いているんだから
自然とのぶつかり合い
対立がそこで生じるんですよ
だから尺度ある限りは人間は苦しみからは脱出はできんですね
そこで仏教は一切の尺度から
解放を推薦するんですね
捨てることを推薦するんですね
そうすると尺度がないんだから
ありのままに見える ありのままに見えたらこれが真理であって
誰でもありのままに見ると同じことですからね
ある人 その画家の絵を私は私の尺度で見て
もう一人の人がその人の尺度で見ると意見が二つでしょうし
二人ともありのままに見るならば
尺度なく置いておいて
で しかし この尺度から自分を解放すること
尺度から脱出することっていうのは
そう簡単というわけじゃないんです
かなり努力しないと 並大抵の努力ではないんですね
で では正しい尺度あればいいでしょ
そんなのはないんですよ
正しい尺度っていうのは
まあ言葉としては生じますよ
邪見に対する正見というのに
でも正しい尺度あるのか？あると言ったらそこで矛盾が生じるんですよ
だから あらゆる見から完全たる自由というふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで 仏教はこのディッティーナンカハーのディッティーナンパティニッサッゴという一切の尺度から
尺度をパハ―ヌ 捨ててしまうこと
ディッティーナンパティニッサッゴも
それも捨てることなんですね
パハ―ヌっていうのは
まあ要はあの受動と能動的な態度で言ってるだけで
あのパハ―ヌでは自分は捨てるということで
パティニッサッゴかっていうと
置いておいて出ていくという
あの受動的態度と能動的態度で
意味は同じでしょうし
すべての尺度から解放っていうのは
自由になること 離れることっていうのは
仏教はまあ絶対大事な仕事として
生きる人はこれやらなくちゃいかんと
これこそ絶対的に大事なこと
だから まあ悟れといおうが
もうなんだかんだよ 仏教の修行はまあそういう尺度からの解放というところで成り立ってます
そこで ありのままに見られれば何なのかという真理もちゃんと語っているんです
では 世の中ありのままに見れば
自分のものをありのままに見れば
完全な普遍的な真理って何なのか
誰が見たっても絶対的な真理で変わらない真理って何なのかと
また堂々とずっと語っているんです
それで人間っていうのは何に努力するべきかと
本当に努力家かと 努力家と
本当に頑張っているんだと
えらい真剣 真面目だと
と言える人っていうのは
この尺度から自分を心を解放するための努力なんです
これこそ難しいんですよ
で 中途半端 曖昧ないい加減な人にはもうただ
じゃあそれはあなたの意見でしょ
これもあなたの意見でしょうとかね
言ってももういい加減なことを言えるんですけど
そんなのももう怠け論理ではないんですよ
こういうわけで尺度がないと
真理はこういうことだからという
これ知恵の開発なんです
だから 優柔不断で曖昧で中途半端で
何一つとも判断できない
この無知な人が頭いいわけじゃないんですよ
その人もそれなりの尺度を持ってるでしょうし
だからこれは智慧の開発で真理が分かったら尺度ができる
全て知ったならばもう角度が必要じゃないんですよ
この角度で見たらこれこれという必要なくなっちゃうんです
この視点で見ればこういうことですよとかね
それでお釈迦様が人間って
特にこれは出家者の話ですから
出家する人は頑張ってるんではないかと
俗世間の欲から離れて
楽な生き方もからも離れて
まあすごい苦労している
それで世間は立派な人
修行者 真剣真面目に頑張っている人
すごい努力家 努力家 精進する人
修行にも徹している人とかね
というふうに世の中は褒める
その これがサンレーカっていう意味なんですね
すごい人って意味なんです
命も惜しまないで頑張ると
目的に達するために 世界はそれを今褒めるんですね
その気持ちがパーリ語でサンレーカという言葉でサンレーカ・ヴィハーラ
そこでまた俗世間のサンレーカとお釈迦様が考えているサンレーカはいつでも違うんです
だからどんな言葉からどんな言葉を使っても
お釈迦様は俗世間が使っている意味と仏教の見方っていうのはあるんです
仏教は尺度がない状態で
尺度から離れた状態から完全な綺麗な心で
ありのままにそのままドーンと直接に物事を見る
俗世間ではそれぞれ自分で作った尺度で物事を見ている
尺度で見るものっていうのは
全く仏教は真理としては認めません
その代わりに言うのは
これは世間論であると
例えばご飯はね 米はおいしいでしょうかと聞いたら
世間ではそう言ってますよと
一部の人間はそう言ってますよというふうな反応なんです
トウモロコシも主食としておいしい
一部の人間はそう思っている
というのは仏教の答えなんですね
人間の体にやっぱり菜食
野菜の方がいいんだと
肉 魚は良くないんだと
一部の人間はそう思っている
やっぱりタンパク質はあるんだから
肉魚適量食べた方がいいんじゃないかなと
そうでない一部の人間もそう思っているというふうな
言うだけであって その通りだとかね
ないんです しかし それまた曖昧じゃないんですよ
生き方として 例えば殺されるようになったら相手を殺しても罪がないと私は思いますよと
言ったら それはあなたはそう思っていますけど
殺すことは罪ですよと
そういう道徳になってくると
厳しくしっかりしている
損することになったら
危険な目に遭うことになったら
やっぱり嘘をついたっても悪くないんだと
それは仏教は認めません
そこら辺では曖昧じゃないんです
哲学的なところになってくると
いい加減しなかって というか
勝手にしなさいよと こちらには関係ないんだということにするんでしょうしね
まあ大体この経典の基本的なポイントはね
で そこでそんなもんですよ
だから 尺度的问题と尺度をなくすということっていうのは
大変な もう信じられないほどの難しいことで
これで修行する人々は
そのために頑張っているんではないかというふうに言って
お釈迦様がこの尺度をなくすことが絶対大変難しいことだから
本物の努力 本物の頑張り
本物の努力家 本物の精進
本当にしっかりしているというならば何なのかということを
それからずっと説明していくんですよ
すぐ そこでまず言ったのは
どこで人間が 特に出家
宗教家が尺度を作るかというと
やっぱり自分に対する尺度と世間に対するいろんな意見
邪見を作るんだよと その二つですよと
普通の俗世間の人々は相手にしてないんです
そんな偉そうなことも考え
何食うかとかね まあご飯はお粥にするか
なんとかにするかとかね
もうそれぐらいの生き方でしたから
服はどんな色 毛は何色にしましょうかとかね
だから これはもう明らかに出家している修行する人々が考える問題で
何食べるか 何を着るか
どこに寝るかということは
出家者の世界ではもうあんまり関係ないんですね
それはどうでもいいということ
だから 自分って何者か
世界って何者かという 2つのポイントに引っかかっている
すごいスケールが大きいんだけど
だから俗人から比べたらすごいスケールが大きいんですね
人間が何で生きているのでしょうかとか
生きることに何が目的があるのでしょうか
どのように生きるべきでしょうかと
やっぱりスケール大きいを感じるでしょ
宇宙はいかにして現れたんでしょうかとかね
すごいスケール大きい人や頭の良い人やとかね
俗世間から見ればスケール大きいんですけどね
仏教はそこら辺からもう説法しているんです
俗世間はすごい巨大なスケール持ってるでしょ
この方々は だから真理知ってるんではなくて
我々はもう晩御飯に何するかっていうことで頭いっぱいのにとかね
だから私たちとは桁違う真理を知ってるんではないかというふうにすぐ思ってたりする
でも私たちは お釈迦様がこの宇宙っていかにして現れたんでしょうかとか
そういうスケールのものを考える人々の立場が 1にして
そこから喋ってるんです
1 というのは そこが一番低次元のところで
尺度の一番低次元なところで
もっと上々あるんだと
尺度っていうのは だからこの断然この経典がスケールが違う
一般の常識に語ってるわけじゃないんです
いわゆるこのすごい宗教家
哲学者も お釈迦様はもうただのガキやこの人という態度から喋ってるんです
ガキと言っても 世間から見れば仙人なんですよ
聖者扱いされてるんですよ
[笑い]それでも尺度っていうのはもう無双に無限にありますからね
これはもう考えられる一番上の一番大きく大きいんではないかと思われる尺度のところから
もう尺度批判に行くんです
これでこのもうちょっと言います
この前に言ったと思いますけど
尺度っていうのは 見っていうのはそれ自体も中途半端曖昧なんですよ
これは私の意見だよと
私はこんな意見で こんな角度で
こんな視野で世の中物事を考えているんだよと言っても
これ自体曖昧なんですよ
尺度というものもグルグルグルグル変わるんですよ
だから すぐすぐ簡単単純で変わる尺度で物事を見ていいんですかと
だから 今日の尺度で何か判断して
もう文章まで書いておいて
明日になってくると自分が別な尺度を持ってるんだから
だから語る権利さえもないんですよ
危ないんですよ 明日別なことを言うんだから
明後日また別なことを言うんだから
人間の人生そういうことでしょう
子供の頃の価値判断セットで
ちょっと年取ったらまた別な価値判断テスト
またまた別な価値判断テストセットでしょうね
これでその時点で これこそ事実
これこそ真理ということで
えらいしつこく頑固でしょうね
もう命までかけちゃう時々
その時の目的に でもちょっと二日
三日置いておけば そのバカが別な意見でいるんですよ
だから面白いんですというか
何一つも当てにならん
頼りにならん人間言うことと人間書く本当か
私で文章を書いた終わった時点で全部きれいさっぱり忘れる
その時点でそう考えただけで
また同じテーマでまた何か書くときも
全く別な視野で書くんですよ
だから俗世間で生きるっていうことは明らかに尺度の話だからね
だからグルグルグルグル変わっちゃうんです
例えば同じ経典を解説するときでも
では哲学的な心理的なものをハイライトしようと思っちゃうと
私の解説はそれなりに変わるんです
では 実践の方をハイライトしようと思っちゃうと
そこら辺だけ徹底的にハイライトする
ハイライトする やっぱり道徳の方がハイライトする
だったらもう道徳の方がハイライトすると
それで語ったりする  [笑い]だからこの
あるいは現代人の思考に合わせようと思うと
また解釈 説は変わっちゃうし
同じブッダの言葉にしても
それぞれ尺度が変わっちゃうんですね
だから自分が安全のために自分がどんな解説
説法しても それを忘れてブッダの言葉だけを覚えておく
そうでなきゃもうどうなるかわからない
どこまで変化するかってのはわからないんですね
これで私たちの尺度っていうのは
まあ一分以内でも何回でも変わったりするし
一日でどれをどこまで変わるかとわからないし
自分の子供は可愛いと言っても
その可愛いという意味がね
ずっと変わっていくんでしょう
同じじゃないんですね
そういうことだから もうほんの瞬間のことで変わる尺度で
我々はそんなにもしがみすぎて絶対的やと思って生きるべきかと
結果としてみたっても苦しみしか出さない結果でしょうに
結果は最悪なんだったらいい加減やめればいいでしょ
これが この方法は それもやめられない
結果いくら悪くてもこのやり方でやるぞと
何もいい結果がなくても
悪い結果しかないと言っても
私はこの道でやるぞという生き方でやってます
そういうことだから そういう尺度はありがたくないということなんですよ
たとえ宇宙の構成を考えるぞと
これからはと 生命って何なのかを私はこれから考えてみるぞと思ったっても
お釈迦様は仏教はもうありがたからないんです
それで出家者たちが修行して
この禅定なんかね 入ってものすごく視野が広くするんですよ
信じられないほど 一番目はこのヴィヴィッチーヴァカーメヒヴィヴィッチャクセレヒダンメヒ
カーマっていうのは 俗世間から心は完全に離れてみて
アクからも離れてみて
思考を働かせて第一禅定に入る
で 集中する で それでこの
集中すると それなりにその方はものすごく幸福感
喜悦感を味わう ということは苦しみが消えたということなんです
視野が広くなった 同時に苦しみが結構消えます
だからヴィヴェーカジャンピイティスカン
大変喜びを感じています
それで論理的に考えちゃうと
尺度を持っちゃうとろくな結果がない
争い 喧嘩 苦しみ 嫉妬 憎しみしかない
でもこの方は苦から完全に離れているし
俗世間からも離れているし
その上すごく喜悦感 喜びを感じているのではないか
苦が減っているのではないかと
素晴らしいとふうに思っちゃうんですよ
論理的に考えても 論理的な構造は
尺度は苦を作る 苦の原因なんです
苦しみの そこである人がこの俗世次元の尺度を全部捨てちゃった
捨てちゃって第一禅定に入りました
入ったところでかなり喜悦感を感じている
そこで彼が目で見て耳で聞いて考えたりすることはしない
ただ ある一つに精神集中して
それについては思考を働かせている
精神集中して だから尺度が抜群に変わったんです
大きくなったんです だからアビダンマではこれを大神というんですね
マハッガタチッタ だから我々は大神じゃないんですよ
もう目で見え 見えなきゃわからない
見えませんし 耳で聞かなきゃ聞こえない
そこだけの世界にもう閉じ込まれているんだから小さいんです
だから大神ではないんですね
アマハッガタチッタなんですね
これで一旦瞑想に頑張ってみた途端
第一禅定が現れてくるし
同時に苦しみっていうのはどーんと減ってしまうというか
ほとんど減ってしまう
喜悦感でいる 大神だ では大神から見ればどうでしょうかと
お釈迦様はそこで言うんです
それでその人が自分がサンレーカ・ヴィハーヤやってるんだと思うでしょうと
私はもう涙っていうのは道路に垂れ流すではないか
しっかり頑張ったと だからこの世の喜びを感じているのではないかと
さすが私だよと思うかもしれませんと
いわゆる修行に励む励んでいると
自分を戒めていると きっちりぎっしりと本人は思うかもしれませんと
しかし ノコパネーテーチュンダ アリアッサ ビネー サッレーカウッチャン
しかし ブッダの世界ではあんなのはサンレーカではありませんと
きっぱりと否定する 第一禅定まで作って
あれほど喜悦感を感じているのに
お釈迦様の単純な定義はディッタ ダンマ スカ ヴィハーヤ
ただ本人が楽に生活していると
すごい現実主義者で 具体的にすごい具体的に楽しんで生活しているんだと
だからそこでこの超越した宗教家と取ってますよ
例えばこの一般的な宗教でいう死んだら天国に行くんだぞとかね
私が死んだらもう神様にもう呼ばれるぞとかね
そんなもう次元の話じゃないんですよ
あまりにも気持ち悪いほどそういう考え方は仏教にはもう次元低いんです
お迎えに来たって話とかね
あんなのは人間考えるんですから
人間で生まれてっていうぐらいですごい低く見るんですよ
だからこちらではそうじゃなくて
すっごい超越して高いレベルの人で
修行者でちゃんと修行して
第一禅定作って あの世で死んでから極楽ではなくて
今生きながらにして極楽を味わっているんですよ
それをお釈迦様は認めます
その人はもう具体的に極楽を味わっている
喜悦感を味わっている
だから ただまあ現実に楽しんでいる人やとは言えますけど
はっきりと楽しんでいる人
申し分はない あの人は幸せだと
幸せで生きている人やということは言えますけど
サンレーカとは言えませんと
努力家やとは言えませんと
戒めているとは言えませんと
で 否定しますね それで
ではある人が そんなお釈迦様にバカにされるんだったら
第二番目の禅定に入ってみるぞと
一切思考さえもやめて
妄想 思考もやめて 第二禅定に入ってみる
それで心はもう完全に統一させているんですね
内というところは サマーディという状態が生まれているんですよ
統一するところじゃないんです
すっごくもう 徹底的に一体になっているというかね
でもお釈迦様 あれはサッレークと言えないんだよと
あんなのは ただ現実的に楽をしている
あれは嘘のインチキな楽じゃないんです
すごい現実的にその人は幸福
気絶感 楽を味わって経験している
でもしっかり頑張っている努力家とは言えませんと
そこで第三禅 三禅定 第四禅定がありまして
第四禅定になってくると
さらにこの尺度っていうのはもう信じられないほど大きくなってるんですよ
いわゆるウペッカー状態なんですね
で 尺度っていうのは好き嫌いで作るんですよ
心が 単純です 我々の偉大なる尺度っていうのは
好きか嫌いかで決めるもんですよ
これ乗り越えてますよ
第四禅定に入ると ウペッカー
不苦不楽というか 捨というかね
何も好き嫌いの判断はない
いい悪いの判断は全くない
それでウペッカーという尺度でいますよ
これがもう想像できる一番大きい尺度なんですよ
第四禅定っていうのは
それでもお釈迦様が これがサッレークとは言えませんよと
ただすごい幸福を感じているだけですと
そこでこの尺度っていうのは
心と体の関係 心と物質の関係なんですよ
心が自分を見るんじゃなくて
物質を見てるんですよ
認識するんですよ 私たちの場合は状態がひどいんですよ
例えば心があって ろくに機能しない
隠れてるんですね それで目を通して
目が物質でしょうに 目を通して目に触れる情報を目の刺激で推測する
あ おそらくあれ綺麗な花を見ているのではないかと
見てないんですよ 心が
えらい隠れているんですよ
すごい惨めな状態で それで目という肉体がありまして
この肉体にいろんな情報が触れる
触れたら肉体は振動する
物質だから 振動しないわけにはいきません
何か触れると そこでこの目という肉体がした振動が
心が 振動を心が受け取って
あれ桜の花だ あれはバラの花だとかね
いい加減なことを考えちゃうんです
それで私は見た あれがバラの花だ
それが綺麗だと あれは目という肉体の状態なんですよ
これが目が壊れているならば
あるいは何か水晶体 何か色でもつけていたならばね
最悪だから それでこの目の後ろに何とか膜があるでしょ
そちらにもこの光の感受性っていうのは人それぞれバラバラなんですよ
それぞれ体が別だから
これで見たと言えるのでしょうかっていうね
それで普通の人々の場合は
あまりにも惨めで 見ることにしたっても
聞くことにしたっても
ろくなことはない で 第四禅定になってくると
まあでもやっぱり物質を見る
知るっていうことをやってますけど
この好き嫌いの尺度っていうのはもう完全に捨ててあって
ウペッカーという平等という冷静に見る
平坦な状態で見ると言う目で認識している
それは第四禅定の状態なんです
それでも信じられないほど尺度はもう広くなっています
なのにお釈迦様はこれまたけなっちゃいますから
あんなのはサッレーカ・ヴィハーラではございませんと
よく頑張っているとはあれでは言えませんと
あれほど頑張っているのに
ただ楽をしているだけやと
それで楽をしているだけっていうことをその分肯定しています
現実にその人は幸福 幸せを感じている
自分で掴んでいる これは認めますけど
努力家ではありません
頑張っているわけじゃないんだ
こんなのはもうちょろいという態度なんです
そんなのは もっと難しいことはあるんだよと
想像できんほど難しいこと
それでさらにその修行者が自分の状態を向上させるんですよ
では物質を認識しなきゃいいでしょ
心は 物質を認識するとウペッカーという尺度が現れるでしょう
では物質を認識しないという無色界の禅定に入ってみるんです
そこで全然物質まるっきり認識しない状態だから
もう尺度っていうのは成り立つはずもないんですけど
しかし それはまあ やっぱり尺度がないと認識できんですよ
そこでこの無色界の禅定
アーカーサーナンチャエタナというね
えーと  空無辺と日本訳しますけど
このアーカーサというのは呼吸状態なんですね
だから呼吸状態を認識すればどうです
そうすると尺度っていうのはなんかないんか
何なのかね 呼吸っていうのは空間のことだから
虚空です  え？空 うん 虚空
これは無限でしょうし
いい悪いとも何の関係もないでしょうし
綺麗か綺麗じゃないか
そんな話にならんし 虚空だからね
それで心は物質ではなくて
虚空そのものを認識しようと思ったら
この無色界の一番目の禅定に入れるんですよ
空無辺という だから もう尺度というものはこれ以上は広げるのかという
だからこちらでこの世の中言ってる
このやっぱり視野は広げた方がいいんだよというところで
お釈迦様があ そうかという態度で
だから俗世間で言ってる視野のとこじゃないんですよ
初めの第一禅定にしても
想像できないほど視野が広げたというところから
またもう本当にもう無限に視野が広げたとしても
だから空無辺禅定っていうのは無限に視野が広げたっていうことなんです
それで物質は認識しないところにまでなっているんです
でもそれもブッダにしてみればサンレーカ・ビハーラではございません
それからこの 虚空そのものも
物質ではないんだけど
なんとなく空間的なものだから
じゃあこれもやめましょうということで
その人それもやめちゃう
次に 色 心が虚空 無辺の虚空を認識したんだから
やっぱり無辺といえば心ではないかと
ということで 心が無辺であるという色無辺禅定に入っちゃうんですね
でも 色無辺 心そのものが無辺ではないかなという状態になっていても
そういうのは経験であって
このただの概念ではないんです
禅定だからね その禅定に入っても
まあこれはあんたすごい楽しているものやというかね
えらい幸せ者やと信じられないほど
だから幸福感を大宇宙ぐらい広げたと考えてください
想像してください これも私たちのイメージの宇宙ではなくて
本当に無限無限大の宇宙なんです
それぐらい巨大に強烈に至福感は感じる
といえば まあこれで十分でしょうに
でもブッダはこれがね
サッレーカになりませんと
ただ楽にいるだけだと
そこで三番目は では無
無という そのもの にしたらどうですかと
無というのはないということでしょ
ではもう釈迦堂がないんじゃないかなと
釈迦堂から脱線したのではないかと
脱線していないんですよ
無という無色 無色界の三番目の禅定に入っても
お釈迦様 あれはサッレーカじゃないんだと
あれも楽に生きているだけよと
では 認識することがこの極端にやめればどうでしょうかと
だから認識しているか認識していないか
どちらかもわからない状態に第四になるんですよ
それでもお釈迦様が  サッレーカとしては認めませんね
しかし この楽とは言わないです
無色界になってくると
サンタービハーラ サンタっていうのは平安
安穏 安穏にいると それなりに言葉は変わってきますけどね
これ以上はもう生命には努力できない
これはもう大宇宙のすべての生命の中で
梵天が誰が認めたっても
この心はもう これはもう究極的なところまで成長させているんです
成長するためには釈迦堂を落とさないと成長はしないんです
だから極端なところまで釈迦堂を落としていったんですよ
言って 非想 非想有情というね
ネーワサンニャーナーサンニャーヤタナという最高な禅定も作ったとします
それは安穏にいるんだというのがはっきりした具体的な安穏を獲得してはいるんだけど
サッレーカとはちょっと遠いと
仏教では だからこの大胆に仏教はこの
この別れて違うんだよということは
このこちらですごく強調するんです
似ている似ている状態ではないんです
そこで何がでしょうかと
サッレーカっていうのは
そこでもう簡単に説明します
本当に努力家 本当に頑張っている
あれ なんでしたっけ？非想
非想有情なんかを獲得するよりも大したもんだと
並大抵のことではないかと
お釈迦様が言っておっしゃっているものは何なのかと
またドーンと我々の日常生活の中に話を持ってくるんです
イダコーパナウォーチュンダサッレーコーカラニヨ
サッレーカ 努力するならば
頑張るならば 戒めな 本物の戒めっていうのは
あの瞑想やらサマーディやら禅定やらヨーガやら苦行やらね
あんなもんじゃないんだと
この超能力はあれやこれやとあるんですけどね
それ何一つのではないんだと
パレーヴィヒンサカーバヴィッサンティ
人々は  加害者である 誰かに何か害を与えている
マエメッタアヴィヒンサカーバヴィッサンティ
私たちは非暴力で生きてみようではないかと
というところで 誰にでも実践できる
すべての人間に だから真理だったら
すべての人間に実践できなきゃおかしいしね
この禅定なんかはね そう簡単じゃないしね
大体おとぎ話みたいなもの
すごい具体的なものなんですけど
簡単に作れるわけじゃないんですよ
だから人は他害 他人に害を与えるんであって
ここで私は害を与えないということに
サンレイコーカラニヨ戒めるべきである
これは本当に戒めなんですよ
例えば 心が本来 自分の利益を考えたりして
自分のことしか考えない
考えられないんですよ
尺度のもとはそこなんですよ
自分のことしか考えられない
他人のことなんか いい加減認めてほしいんですよ
私は知ってるのは私のことだけやと
全然誰もそれを認めてくれないんですよ
みんな善人被りをする
私は人のことを心配しているんだとかね
あなたのことは心配しているのではないかとか
まあうるさいこと 結局は誰も誰のことも心配してはないし
だったらこの世の中簡単に良くなるでしょうに
隣の人も私のことを心配するんだったら
これ自体でも最高でしょうに
なんで人間がそんなに苦しんでるんですかね
嘘だからでしょ 誰も誰のことも心配してないんで
心配することできんですよ
自分のこと知らないんだから
結局は自分のことを心配してるんですよ
私 すごく子供が好きなのはそういうわけなんですよ
すごい正直で よく大人のことを心配するんですよ
大丈夫 なんとかとかね
お前本当は自分のこと心配してるでしょと聞けば
すぐバレちゃうんですよ
だからお母さんでもちょっとちょっと体調が悪くなっちゃって
寝たりすると 子供が小さいんだったら結構母親のことを心配するんですよ
なんとかしてあげようと思ったり頑張ったりをする
これは自分には晩ご飯なくなったら困っちゃったっていうことなんで
簡単に どうしよう 母ちゃんが病気だったら晩ご飯がっていうことになる
だからそれはその教えてあげた方がいいんですよ
日本ではやっぱりやりませんからね
いい子だなとか いい子ですねとかね
だから一生嘘だけで生きてみてね
私一人ではこの苦しみなくせませんと思いますよ
この嘘で始めて嘘で終わるんだからね
自分の母のことは一回だけ心配したんですけどね
このこのココナッツの木の下で仕事してはいかん
「これこう危ないんだよ」と
ココナツの木の下っていうのは本当に危ないんですよ
葉っぱでも一枚落ちたら死んじゃいますからね
葉っぱ一枚なんですけど
大きさが違うんだから
で 私は別に母がずっと言ってることはもう繰り返しただけ
我々は遊んでるとすぐ怒られる 「
なんでそちらで遊ぶんですか」と
で そんなところで遊ぶと
という我々に言う説教する母が
自分が堂々とココナツの木の下で座って何かやっていたんです
それ言ったら 「ああ お前
本当にお母さんのこと心配するんでしょ」と言ったことはないんですよ 「
何のこと？」私の顔見て 「
お前 自分のこと心配してるでしょ？」それで私はわからなかった 「
だって私が死んじゃったらお前困るんだから 」「
私が死んじゃったら困るのはお前でしょう」すごい冷静で
それ事実ですよ で 私すごく恥ずかしくなっちゃったんです
自分では別にそういう考え方があったわけでもないんですけど
考えてみればそれでしょうしね
結局は だから自分は考えていなかったんだけど
それは考えていたんですよ
それははっきりと教えてくれるんだからね
ですから この  そういうふうなことはした方がいいと思います
そうするとやっぱり人間っていうのはしっかりはするし
人間になるし で はっきり言えば
我々は自分のことしかわからない
自分のことしか心配していない
これで世間に対してもう説教するなりに
まあアドバイスするなりに
もうみんなで平和で頑張りましょうと
もういいだよ あんた自分のことしか考えてないでしょうと
平和のとはいい加減にしてください
うるさいよと まあ本当に考えるんだ世界は平和になるでしょうに
そんな世界平和っていうのはくだらんこと考えなくたって
もう二 三人で平和でいれば
自分が付き合ってる 自分の友達二
三人とも平和でいられない人が世界平和のためにとかね
だからこちらではこの徹底した真理
すべての生命が自分のことしか知らない
だからいとも簡単に加害者に変わっちゃうんですよ
心が言うんですよ 自分のためにあれやりなさい
これやりなさいと だってあの椅子はお前を侮辱したでしょう
だから言い返せと 殴っちゃえと
これがどんな心にも自然に表れてくる本能なんです
自分のためならもう他人に害を与えてはいいという
この本能そのものをなくそうと努力するんですよ
だから世間の人々はもういつでも他人
他人に害を与えている
私は加害者には絶対ならないよと
そこはでも自分のことですよ
私は加害者にならないようにするんだぞということだから
あの人かわいそうだから
やっぱり弱い人は守ってあげなくちゃいけない
あれは偽善ですよ やっぱり弱い人々には親切にしなくちゃいけない
障害者には親切にしてしなくちゃいけないとかね
みんな兄弟だから やっぱり真面目にみんなのためにもう害与えて
そういう考え方はブッダは嘘やと思ってるんです
偽善だと だから世の中一向に良くならないんだと
本当のところ あんたはあんたのことしか知らないんだと
だから自分が加害者にならないようにということで頑張ってくださいと
それがみんな否定すること
誰もやろうとしないんですよ
簡単なの かっこつけてホームレスの人々を助けましょうとか
マザー・テレサ志向で生きてみようとかね
あんなのはいとも簡単にどんなバカにもできます
それでは仙人になりません
マザー・テレサの話聞いてみたって
えらい仙人の一かけらもないってことわかるでしょうに
ただ毎日朝晩神にお祈りしなきゃ
神にもうすがり込んでいなきゃ仕事できないんだと
だったら私たちは何が違いますかね
私たち あ 嫌だ もう気持ち悪いんだからあっち行こうっていうぐらいのことで 「
神様」ってことでやってるだけの
大体このマザー・テレサ主義っていうのは簡単ですよ
しかし この自分の心を見て
心が自然に衝動を起こしちゃうんですよ
本能として害を与えろという
自分のために どんな言い訳もする
でも殺されるようになったらという質問するでしょ
やっぱり自分のことしか考えてない
し 嘘は言わないと思ったところに
私はすごく損失したらどうしますかねとかね
やっぱり自分のことしか考えてないんです
やっぱり殺生は悪いんだけど
やっぱり人が食べる分ぐらいはね
これはしょうがないでしょう
自分のことしか考えてないんですよ
だから善人ではありません
頑張ってるわけでもないんですよ
エゴを守ることって誰でもやってるんだから
だから本当に努力っていうのは
このエゴを守らないための努力なんです
だからお釈迦様には あのヒンドゥー教で
ブッダ バラモン教で あるいは他の宗教で
ものすごい何十年も苦労して修行してサマーディ瞑想と経験とかあるのにも関わらず
そんなのはまあちょろいことやと誰にでもできるよと言った人で
サッレーカではないんだと
ただ暗黒にいるんだと
言っても その禅定があったのは仏教の人々だけなんですよ
こんな中途半端な法で禅定は作れます
作られませんし 一応お釈迦様は論理的には誰にでもできますよってことだけを言っておいただけで
証拠としてお釈迦様は引用しているは何人かだけな仏教以外は
この禅定の経験があった人を通して
お釈迦様は何人かの名前を挙げています
それもその時代ではなくて
もっと古い時代の話なんです
そこでお釈迦様に瞑想して
初期的な瞑想したアーララーカーラマとウッダカラーマという二人も
まあ立派やと 本当に賢者やとは言ってるんですね
だから何人かしかいなかったんです
まあいたでしょう でもあまり有名ではなかったし
そんなにインド文化に影響を与えたわけでもないし
それはそれでも それでもそれは否定して
まあ害を与えないように戒めべきであると
それ 2番目はパーナ 殺生でしょ
人は生命は殺生する そんなのは当たり前
自分を守るためには殺生する
食べるために殺したっていうことも
自分を守るためなんですよ
強盗に入ったところで
もう顔バレたんだから殺したと
これも自分を守るためでしょうに
自分を守りたいんだけど
強盗には入るわ 人は殺すわ
殺してから言い訳はするわ
これって人間かと で 通り魔やら色々させたりするでしょう
逃げること 人に怪我させて
自転車に乗って オートバイに乗って
サッと何か誰かにね 信じられない
この堕落している状態っていうのは
で 人っていうのは やっぱり自分のために人を殺して
生命を殺して 殺した時点からまたさらに逃げたりして
結局自分を守る 自分を守る
それしか知らない だからそちらには何の道徳もないということは
仏教ははっきりするんですよ
自分を守るだけっていうのは道徳ではないんだと
この場合はね これはすっごいレベル高い話ですよ
こんな説明しても皆様は分かってないという波動が
私はじーっと感じて時々嫌になっちゃうんですよ
もう喋ってる途中でもすぐ嫌になる
やっぱりこれはもうダメやと
わからないんだと それはもう
あの それ難しいんですよ
言ってるレベルは だから本当の道徳っていうのは
やっぱり自分 自我を エゴを守ることじゃない
エゴを潰すことなんです
私 殺されたっていいんじゃないですか
殺されたっても 私は殺しませんよと
という態度なんです 私は殺しません
あなたを殺しに今四人が来ているんだと
東西南北から まあだからと言ったってどうせ死ぬことでしょうし
私はもう攻撃はしませんと
ということが本物の努力
だからこれが命に関わることだからね
だから瞑想あれ サマーディ瞑想
あれよりははるかに難しい
きつい まあ大体そこら辺で行典は終わったことにしようかなと思ってます
それで あの アブラクマチャーリー
みんなもう性的な関係を持って
あの 何と言いますか 人間って
生命っていうのは何のために生きてるかというと
子孫を作るために生きてるんですよ
その子孫は何のために来るかというと
その子孫は何のためにかというと
また子孫を作る こういうロクなこと生き方やってないんで
ただそれだけの人生なんです
人間の場合でも ですから
それはやめているんだと
これがこの遺伝的なものだから
生きてるものが これが唯一の生きる目的だと思ってるんです
子孫を作ること だから体力ある若い時は子孫を作っちゃって
それからそこを大きくするまではもう命賭けちゃうんです
かけて自分が死んじゃうんです
じゃあ私が死んでも悔しくはないんだと
だって子供作りましたからと
そいつも同じことをやって悔しくないんだと
死んじゃいますからもう
だからこれも遺伝的なことで
誰でもやってること やっぱりそこをやめるっていうことは大切なものなんですよ
それからみんな嘘をつく
私は嘘をつかない それで自我を守らないんですね
そちらでも みんな陰口を言う
私は陰口をしないようにと努力する
戒める みんな暴言を吐く
私は暴言を吐かないように
みんな無駄話をする 私は無駄話をしないように戒めると
これ一つ一つ自分のことなんです
自分を守るためにやってるものなんです
自分を守るために他人に迷惑かける
だからこうやってこの道徳を守るためには
自分の命をかけなきゃダメなんですよ
瞑想には命はかけなくてもできますよ
俺がやったぞと自慢できるんだからね
今こういうこういう経験を得ているんだぞとかね
自我はいいところなんですよ
しかし この戒律を守るために
道徳を守るために 自分の命もかけなくちゃいけないんです
だからここは一番難しいことだから頑張ってちょうだいと
それからみんな強欲であって
私は強欲にならんように戒める
みんなこの激怒する 私は激怒しないように
みんな邪見を持っている
まあ意見ではなくて邪見持ってますよ
だからこれ一番質が悪いんですよ
私は正見になるようにと努力すると
ちゃんとわからなかったというのは何で邪見？ 邪念
あ 邪念 じゃあその通りです
えーと みんな邪思惟もある
我々が間違ってる考え方
思考です 私たちは正しい思考でいるんだと
で 邪業していて 我々は邪業をしないようにと努力する
正業に努力する 戒める
それから正業と正命がね
生活するためには他人に身をかけていて
生きるために仕事を通して私はサンマアジを正しい仕事で生活するんだと
それからこの邪念 邪念がわからないと
これ書いてるでしょうに
精神的な混乱 怒り 落ち込み
引っ込みなどを引き起こす思考
妄想でしょうに 正念っていうのはサティでしょ
サティがない場合はすべて邪念なんですよ
わからない 例えば引っ込み状態になったらえらく頑張ってるでしょうに
それでスーッと そういうのを邪念というんですよ
例えば学校は怖いだ みんな友達は大嫌いだとかね
私のことバカにするんだ
学校に行きたくない そればっかり悶々悶々と考えて引っ込みになるでしょ
立派な邪念ですよ  気づきがないことですか
気づきがない  それも一つです
で 他人は邪智者っていうね
間違ってる変な思考 神は絶対なりやとかね
魂は永遠なりやとかね
知ったこともない 見たこともない
経験したこともない いい加減なこと堂々と言って世の中混乱させてるんですね
しかし我々は正智者になると
サンマニャーニ で ここからこのサンマサマーディではこの八正道終わっちゃうんですよ
この これが微妙に書いてますよ
これ悟りの道書いてますから
単なる道徳の本じゃないんですよ
本当に戒めるということは
完全に一切の見 尺度を捨てることなんですよ
それには順番があるんだよと
まずエゴを捨てろと 自分のために嘘をつくっていうことはやめましょうと
というところから始めて
八正道を頑張ってみて
八正道が終わったところでサンマニャーニ
智慧が現れる そこでもう絶対神は絶対なりやという話ではなくて
まあ一切は無常でありやと
無我であって苦であるということがサンマニャーナなんですよ
これもちゃんとした経験で発見する
だから一切の見が 尺度が無くなると
これが綺麗ですか？と聞いたっても出てこないんですよ
綺麗っていうのは尺度でしょ
では汚いかというと それも尺度
これ壁ですか？と 壁っていうのは判断でしょうし
と こういうふうにあると壁であって変わったら壁で
これ倒したら壁じゃないでしょうに
すぐ変わりますからね
だから何でも変わるんだからということで
変わるというところで止まっちゃうんです
無常というところで それ少年なんですよ
そこでもう他人は邪解脱
解脱よと勘違いして いろんなあれが解脱
これが解脱と言ってるでしょうに
だけど仏教ではそうではなくて正解脱
正しい解脱を考えている
それで八正道は十項目にするんですよ
ここら辺でやめましょう
先生 確認してよろしいでしょうか
邪見者と邪痴者っていうのはまた違うものなのですか？ うん
何 まあ順番的にはね ちょっと上ですけどね
似ているといえば似ていたっても別に問題はないし
順番で書いてるんだからね
見よりはあっちへは まあ一番上ですよ
じゃあ今までの話について
じゃあ皆様もいろいろ意見はあったりとかすると思いますけど
まあ私がいるとなんか設問
質問は出てこないわ 全然
あれでしょうね 相手にされてないね
だからあの せっかくこのエハラさんとかね
あの 囲んでいろいろお話をしてみたらいかがでしょうかと
どうしますか？休憩いたしますかね
休憩しちゃうとまた帰ってこないという
ありがたい性格もありますよ
だから一旦このみんなね
輪を取ってでも作って
じゃあ頑張ってください
では ここからは第二部で
あの 今のお話について少し話をしたいなと思いますが
あの よろしければエハラさん
あの 前の方に来ていただいて
とりあえず丸くなって
ちょっと話 感想言ってみますか
やりますか  感想ありますか？皆さん
そんな 佐藤さんが中心になって皆さんのご意見を聞いて
で 進めてください  エハラさんがここら辺にお座りになれば
で 私は一応オブザーバーで
メンバーではなくて 司会は佐藤さんで
会長はエハラさんで じゃあお願いします
ちょうどその辺をおっしゃってましたので
ぜひ前の方に来ていただけますか
お願いします  そこまでは行きますけど
ここまで来てください
いや どうぞ どうぞ  司会をしますので
どうぞ エハラさん  まあまず何かね
エハラさん何かお話した方が皆様に喋りやすいとかも
まあとにかくこの後世を育てておかないと
今日はね 身動きがよくないので
どうぞよろしくお願いします
えー今のお話が  今までのことをよくわからない
お願いします どうぞ お時間ももったいないから
え まあではあの 江原さんに限らず
今日のお話の感想など
感想やご意見などありましたら出していただければと思いますが
いかがでしょうか あの素朴にここのところがわからなかったとか
あのもう少し聞いて この部分を聞いてみたいというような意見でも良いかと思うんですけど
どうですか  はい えっと
判断とか解釈をしないっていうことがあったんですけど
これは読めばあれだろうって言われるかもしれないですけど
これの諫めるっていうことを読んで
他人に害を与えないように諫めましょう
諫め うん 他人に害を与えない方がいいと判断する
して判断して判断して判断していくんじゃないかなっていうのは思ったんですけど
どうですか？今意見考えてください
何ページですか？ いえ
ただページに関係ないんです
はい？ページとかじゃなくてですね
うんと  彼が言うのは 例えば他人に害を与えないように戒めましょうと言ったら
まあ判断はダメだと言ったんですけど
まあこれが判断ではないかという
そんなことは当たり前だから判断ではないっていうことでしょうか
だから素朴的に言えば
判断が悪いと散々言って
最後には判断しましょうって言ってることではないかと
では その疑問はどう解決すればよろしいかということです
じゃあ頑張ってください
[笑い]質問は私だけ
誰か我こそは答えられるという人いませんかね
で ここに書いてあるのは
あの 時代とか文化で左右される物差しじゃなくて
真理であるっていうことで
まあ受け入れるっていうか
そういう風に僕は理解したんですけども
それで もう一つ もう一つっていうか
それに被せるわけじゃないですけど
真理に対しても なんかお釈迦様が説いてることに対しても
何に対しても一応本当かなっていう風に疑ってみて
自分で検証して それで判断するっていうか
まあそれも判断ということ
まあ結局はなんか屁理屈かもしれないけど
判断なんじゃないかな
またもややっぱその自分のとりあえずその時の尺度で判断して
いいか悪いかを決めて
そのステップアップじゃないけど
お釈迦様のお釈迦様の言葉をお釈迦様の言葉を正しいと判断するということの自分の判断ではないかと
だから 私はそうですね
やっぱり人はもうそれぞれもう自分の意見っていうか
自分持ってるしかないじゃないですか
それ以外に判断の基準がないっていうことはもうすごく当たり前っていうか
それが前提ですよね だからその前提で最終的な結論として
ディッティをなくすっていうことが最終結論としてあるんだけれども
ではその最終結論に至るために使う道具は何かっていうと
自分のディッティしかないんじゃないかなって思うんですよ
で まあ道徳的に人間が人を殺してはいけません
害を持ってはいけません
盗ついてはいけませんっていうのは
ごくごく自分のものに判断に照らし合わせてても
自分の経験 今まで生きてきた経験から言っても
ああそうだなという風に判断は本当に自分の判断ですけれどもね
様々な判断があると思いますけど
その中でできると思うんですよ
そういう中で いつもいつも釈尊が言っている教え
そういうのを害を持たないっていうことはどういうことかっていうことを
いつも自分の物差しの中で
自分の物差しと釈尊の物差しっていうのをこう突き詰めて
あの こう置いておいて
その場その場でやっぱり自分の判断をしていって
やっぱり あの 選んでいって選んでいくしかないですね
判断していくしか生きていくんだから
そういう中で少しずつ少しずつ
こう なんていうの 選り分けられていって
だんだん自分を綺麗にしていくことなんではないかなって思うんですよね
それしかないんでしょ
判断していくしか生きていく道っていうのは
あの長老がおっしゃったようにないからね
で そういう中でやっぱりいろいろな
あの なんて言うか あの
もう生きていく その場その場の判断を自分が上手に使う
あと釈尊の教えもその判断の基準として使う
だから私思って 長老の話を思って聞いてたんですけど
受信-- 受信能力ってありますよね
だから 果たしてこれでお釈迦様の-- 長老がおっしゃっているお釈迦様の教えが私のところにちゃんと入っているのかなっていうのは
これ疑問っていうとね
そのまま受け取れるっていうのは絶対ないだろうっていう思いなんですよね
だから うん もう判断 判断は自分の判断で
で 釈尊の教えを絶えず突き詰めていくっていうやり方で
で やっぱりすごく簡単なところからだんだんだんだんすごいレベルアップしていってるから
それはもう自分の能力とあれしていくしかないんじゃないかなって思いますけれども
突き詰めていくことによって自分の尺度を壊していくというか
そうですね やっぱり広げていくっていう
それで最終的にはなくなるっていうことだと思いますけれども
私はね そう思ってます
はい  どうでしょうか 随分詳しい詳しい説明をね
していただいた他に言いたいことないですかね
で その質問を井原さんに出してみたら
今のあの簡単に話しましたけど
要するに自分のお釈迦様のディッティを超えろというメッセージを自分が実践するためには
自分のディッティを使わなきゃいけない
でもその自分のディッティで
その例えばお釈迦様が言ったことを判断するんだけど
でも自分のその中でその判断しながら
でもお釈迦様の基準と自分の持っているその狭いディッティのものとをなんか
いつも合わせ鏡じゃないですけど
いつもそれを比較して考えていきながら実践することで
だんだんそれが自分の方が敗れて
自分の方の小さなディッティの方が敗れていくということなんじゃないかということをつばささんが今おっしゃった
つばさがおっしゃったですね
はい  私はわかりません
[笑い] 他その-- そっち今出された質問について他の方々意見ございませんかね
あの これは私のあの あれなんですけど
あのヴィパッサナー瞑想を
そうあの してるわけじゃないので
言うのはちょっと何なんですけれども
感覚がすごくあの あの
なんていうか敏感になってきますと
ここに書かれてあること
を の その「じゃ」がついていることを
その感覚として波動として受けると
ものすごく苦しいというか
痛みとして感じるので
それはそうするとそれが良くないっていうこと[笑い]
ちょっとうまく説明できないんですけど
あの 波動としてそういうものがこう
もうすごく満ちてるわけです
それを感じるとすごく苦しいですね
それはちょっとだから自分も出してるわけです
いつかあの調合も申し上げたんですけど
みんななんか毒ガスをね
まき散らして生きてるんですよ
すごく苦しい そのことがわかれば
あの唯一の方法は あのサティをし続けることしかないですよね
その今さっきその場その場でその釈尊の言われたことと自分の尺度を合わせながら判断していくって
判断するときに使う道具というかとしてサティがあるっていう
いろんな場面で付き合ったときに判断-- 判断っていう
どっちが正しいかどっちが合うとかっていうことじゃ-- まあ一緒にね
わかっちゃう それが実践できてるかどうかでちょっとたまに荒れるんですけど
あの 例えば喜びの-- 苦しいことだけじゃなくて
喜びのあのなんかすっと静かな時に
-- なんていうか なんか嬉しいことがあっての喜びじゃなくて
こう喜びの感情が出てるんですよね
それも苦なんですね 私にとっては
とか 例えば赤ちゃんはすごく嬉しいことがあって
もう嬉しいさでこうすると泣いちゃいますよね
苦なの 苦だからだよ 赤ちゃんがすごくあの
誰か好きな人たちのうちなどに行っても
喜んじゃって興奮しちゃって
でも喜びがすごくこうなると
あの 泣いちゃいますよね
赤ちゃんとかちっちゃい子ってそうなんです
すごく喜びの極みで泣いちゃうんです
あれやっぱり喜びもすごく苦だと思う
そこはもちろんあの すごくあの
苦の あのことっていっぱいあるわけですけど
喜びも苦だ そうするとあの
本当にこう鏡 あの山の水面のように静まってないと全部苦だと
私は そのことがこう体に感じる波動でわかってくれば
もうここに書かれてあることは
じゃがついてることは全部すっごいあの毒ガスの波動を出していることになるよと
思い込み  いやあの二人とも意見にまとめて
一応まあ自分の意見を言いますけど
あの この あの判断をなくすためによりベターな判断をするということではありません
[笑い]よりベターな判断でも判断ですからね
問題はなんで判断するのかと
これはエゴですよ 常に我々はもう一番最初の判断というのはエゴなんです
私はがというただその言葉で意味するものなんですよ
私が見るでしょ あれは綺麗と次に言うでしょ
綺麗ということを判断なんですけど
では私がということは何なのかと
それは判断ですよ だから一切の判断の土台は私がというエゴなんです
そこで ではこの私がって何なのかと
そこら辺分析してみるのはヴィパッサナー実践なんですよ
そこで私がっていうのは元々なかったと
あれはただの判断でしたかということに悟るんですよ
と同時に一切の判断はもうひとかけらもなく消えちゃうんです
そこで すべての判断の大本
母体は私がというエゴ
私がいるんだというエゴ
こちらの方おっしゃっているように
いろんな我入っているものはすべて苦しいんだと
すごく苦しい だから苦しいと判断するのも私がというエゴなんですよ
これ潰しちゃえば これはエゴはないんですよ
これは単なる判断ですよ
いい加減な と言っても我々もうとっくに判断しているんだから
一切の判断の母体だからエゴは
だからやるならばエゴを破るために頑張るんですよ
修行でも瞑想でも何でもないんですよ
それでエゴを破るために私たち判断ばっかりやっている
判断しが生きる価値がない我々はどこから始めればいいかというと
まあやっぱりみんな害を与えながら生きているんですよ
生きるために エゴを守るために
では私は害を与えないことにするんだぞと決めた時点でエゴが震えるんですよ
例えば殺生はしないぞと決めたら
もう判断ではないんですよ
判断と言ったっても構いませんだけど
そこで皆殺生するんだから
私は殺生しないんですよ
皆は殺生することに判断している
そこで私は殺生しないと決めた瞬間で
私がえらい危うく状態になっちゃうんですよ
もう死ぬ覚悟でやらなくちゃいけないんですね
これで何が壊れるかというと
エゴが壊れるんです それで判断がなくなっちゃうんです
だからこれがもうこの-- これは方法で
この判断の母体を壊そうとしているんです
この私たちの日常生活でやっている
もうくだらない判断について
別にお釈迦様は別にそこはもう気にしないんですよ
例えば子供を見たら お前可愛いなとか
お前うるさいな本当にという
そんなぐらい判断を別にとったことないんですよ
この一切の判断する母体
エゴという判断 それもまた判断なんですね
エゴあるっていうこと自体に
だからそこには着するんですよ
この仰天 だから新しい判断を作ったとも言い切れないんですよ
判断作るのはエゴで判断するんだから
まだまだエゴがあるんだから当然判断ですよ
しかし ちょっと違うんですよ
これがたとえで言えば
この森を壊すために森の木が必要でしょ
そういうことで この判断をこたっぱしから山火事にして灰にしてあげれば
エゴというところからエゴに火をつけておくんです
全部燃えるんだと ということだと思います
先生 今のことに関連してなんですけれども
例えば何か話をしてですね
人を悲しい その人が相手が話したことによって傷ついた
その時には その相手が傷ついたということを観察するのか
それとも自分がそれを言った時のその心を観察するのか
どういう風に どちらが正しい？ どちらが正しいってことではないんです
やりやすいことをやった方がいいんですよ
その場合はね 傷ついた相手のことを観察することがやりやすいならば
それを観察する あるいはそういう言葉を発した自分の心を観察できると思うならば
やりやすい やりやすい方でやればいいと思いますよ
それでわかった 例えばそれで気が付いたことを自然にして
戒めなくちゃいけないんですね
行動より戒めるんですよ
やっぱり  [笑い]まあいろいろ出してみてください
今まあ私喋っちゃうとまあ
あのひとつ僕の感想なんですけど
あの この四十四項目あるんですけど
みんなこんなたくさんちゃんと覚えてたのかなっていうのが一つ疑問なんですけど
例えばあの先生がいて
じゃあ最初は一から十までやって
七 一から十までですかね
十までやってくださいって
できましたって 次はじゃあ八正道やりなさいとかっていう感じで
例えばまあじゃあ沙弥は
沙弥になったばっかの人は一から十まで覚えなさいとかっていう感じならわかると思うんですけど
最初にいきなり四十四言われても
なんのこっちゃかというような
それぞれダブってるような気もしますし
よくわからないんじゃないかなという気はしたんですけど
なんか一発でこれを全部...全部覚えなきゃいけないようなもんなんでしょうかね
全然関係ないこと言ってもいいですか？関係ないこと言ってもいいですか？いや
あの 覚えるとか覚えないとかではなくて
あの これは私たちの心をきれいにするための
あの お釈迦様の説いた教えだと思うんですよ
で それを私たちの心丸くなって勉強して
で あの エゴをなくすために
に 今どうしたらいいかってことを丸くなって
あの 話し合いをしてるわけで
で あーなくなったねって思えば
それが成功してお釈迦様のものが
ことが私たちに入ったんだけれども
多分私はこれが終わって帰ってもエゴはなくならないと思うんですね
私がね じゃあこれが あの
少しでも あの 今日の時間が活きるためには
結局何を一つ持って帰ればいいのかなって思うと
何かな 我をなくすって言っても
エゴをなくすって言っても
うーん まず一つどれからやろうかなって思うんですけど
では皆様意見出してみて下さい
四十八項目ですね  四十四
あ 四十四 四十四項目すべてを覚えておくべきか
あるいは自分で一つ二つぐらい選んでそれに頑張るべきかとかね
四十四も覚えるのはめんどくさいのではないかとかね
いろいろ意見があります
こんなの覚えられませんと
覚えられないところで頑張るっていうことはありえないと
はい どうぞ  じゃあ その一つ選ぶとした場合ですね
自分にとって一番やりにくいものを選ぶのか
それとも一番やりやすいものを選ぶのか
どうやって決めましょう
では まず選ぶか選ばないかっていうことを考えてみましょうか
それは選ぶことになったならばの話ですけど
まあまあ それはどんな意見でも大丈夫です
別にね 意見だからね そんなに気にする必要ないんで
意見に執着する必要ないんですよ
ただの意見だから  やりやすいやつを選んでいいんでしょうか
自分にとってやります
その場合は その場所の精進の努力の仕方が
もし問題問題点が提起されているわけだと
努力を努力を積算する命がけで努力をしたいっていうことをおっしゃっているわけです
一番やりやすいのだと
自分だけにはならない
いや やらなくていいって
意味すると あれはもう大変です
だからその大変とか完璧とかっていうのを置いといて
そういうそう言ってしまったら
何でも逃げることになってしまう
だから本当にこう一つやるんだったら
やろうと思ったならば
真正面から真正面もうきちっと
何が何でもこれだけは守り抜くぞっていうのを心に入れといて
で そうするとその他のこともどうできるかという可能性はあるんじゃないかなと
だから それはやりやすいのを選んだ方がいいのか
初めての いや 同じこと考える
はい 私ね 一番の質問になんですが
おべその一番の一番のね
他人に害を与えたりしないので
それがいつもおべそでおべそで走るのが多い
ちょっと私にも聞き取れない
言ってることは 江原さんだけじゃないんです
他人に害を与えて書いてますね
そういうことがいつもこの私にずっと頭から離れないで
ついこれから何かあれを考える時も
こう心がもうおべそをかいてる自分にしてる
あの 悲しくなって それは害を与えていない
害を与えつって その言葉を読むと
いつもなんかね 自分が人に害を与えちゃうんじゃないかと思って心が辛くなってしまう
はい おじさんまた意見言っていい？ あ
どうぞ お意見をリーダー
私 あの お釈迦様のね 二種工業っていうお経がすごくやっぱり心に入って
これは自分のために 何だっけな
自分のためになるかならないか
それで相手のためになるかならないかっていう
やっぱりいいことか悪いことかっていうことを
二つの物事は二つの考え方で分けましょうっていう
あの お経だったと思うんですけど
そういう風に  これ見ると
害を与えることがいいことか悪いことか
あの まあ悪いこと 害を与えないことがいいことみたいに
何でもこう いいことと悪いことの二つにシンプルに分けて
あの 考えればいいかなって思ってるんですよ
あの 要するに一つのことだけだったら
あとは知りませんみたいな感じにもなりかねないから
まあその場その場で何でもまあちょっとっていう風には考えたんですけれども
うん  えっと じゃあ私が考えたことなんですけど
さっきあの 江原さんが
あの エゴをなくすっていう風におっしゃったんですけど
えっと 私は今日先生の言葉で
あの 自分のエゴを守らないようにする努力っていうのが
すごく ああ そういうことなんだなって
あの 戒めっていう意味が
あの 思ったんで そのことを
何て言うか 覚えて帰りたいなというふうに思ったんですけど
まああの 江原さんに意見聞いてみましょう
あの 害を与えないということが心に引っかかっちゃっている場合はどうすればということをね
害を与えないということが心に引っかかっている
ご質問  はい  めそめそしているんだって
[笑い] 私も随分長いことを生きておりますけど
その生きている間には色々自分の考えも変わりましたけれども
最晩年になって このテーラワーダの会員にさせていただいて
長老様のお話を伺っている間に
いつでしたか 一度長老様が
あの 正当防衛は成り立たないって一言おっしゃいました
で それ以来 私はもう私も諦めて
正当防衛は成り立たない
死ぬ時があったら死にましょうと思って毎日暮らしております
そう 本当にそれを偽らない気持ちでございます
でも おかげさまでまだ私を殺しに来た人がいませんしね
でも そういう人が来たらば
私が長老様が正当防衛は成り立たないって一言おっしゃったことを守って
にっこり死にたいと思って暮らしております
それで皆様はこの四十四の一つ二つ守ればいいという立場ですかね
はい  すいません 私なんですけど
こういう取説がすごい欲しかったので
普通機械の取説は読んでもあんまりわからないんですけど
何？何？ 取扱説明書 スジコのっていうのがあって
すごいいいなと思って
面白いなと思って読んでまして
自分では解脱をしたいなっていう願望がありますので
最初からこの四十何個あるかわかりませんが
毎日朝と夜をただ理々の瞑想のごとく読んでおりますというのをやってるから
あんまり深く考えないで
それをただ実践だけですので
全部自分に当てはまるんですね
これが もちろん人も追加で入れました
あ そうだ そうだということで
そういう風にならないようにというところまで読んでるっていうのが
今現在毎日続けております
だからあんまり深く考えてなかったんで
今日はとっても参考になりました
どうもすいません  で 私がどちらかというと
今の意見には私は一応偏りますけどね
またいろいろ意見があると思いますから
一応この意見について自分の考え方を言います
はっきり言うと この四十四項目も覚えておいた方がいいんです
これは一つも削除することできない
削除してみてください
この項目は守らんでもいいと
何か出してみて 四十四の中でこれがそんなにうるさい
言わなくたっても大目に見たってもいいんじゃないかなという何か項目はありますか
これも最大公約で削減した結果の公約ですね
だったら何一つ実行はできる
いえいえ それはご自分の判断でね
だから自分の判断としては
それを自分に苦しむというか
もう無理してじゃなくて
一つずつ何か出会うことがあると思うんです
この項目の中の何か生活してる中にね
その時にあ これだったんだ
あれだったんだって思いながら少しずつ進めていくしかこの年にしてないと思ってます
はい いいですか？私喋っても
お願いします  それであの四十四項目の中で何か一つありますか？何か一つ
三十四  三十四 何で何だ？三十四って何でしたっけ？その時
反抗的な人には行動するためには素直になるということがありますけど
ドゥッバチャ・スワチャですね
反抗まではいかないんですけど
あんまり素直に何でもはいはい聞きすぎるのも良くないんじゃないかと
これがね これドゥッバチャ・スワチャの意味ははっきり表現できないんですよ
日本語で ドゥッバチャっていうのはこのものすごい
すごい頑固塊っていうことなんです
全くも人の考え方 アドバイスなんかはもうもう立ち入りできません
自分の中で 硬い硬い壁を
え？頑固 頑固 頑固そのものなんで
ドゥッバチャの意味はね
この頑固ということは後で思い出したんだけど
まあ本はもう出ているしね
で それについてほんのちょっと私は最近文章は書いたんですけど
三十二に頑固って入れてる
え？三十二は頑固にしているんだから
なるほど 硬いというね
ドゥッバチャも結局は頑固で
ワチャだから word
だから 他人のアドバイスは絶対受け入れないということでは向上はもう認めませんね
その人には そのまんまで
で 素直っていうのは何でもはいはいということじゃないんですよ
自分を向上したいんですよ
だから私は文章で書いたのはこういうことなんです
みんな本来ドゥッバチャである
私もドゥッバチャで 皆様方もドゥッバチャなんですよ
で 人の話は聞きたくない
人が何かアドバイスするとどうしても心が反抗を起こしちゃうでしょ
これは赤ちゃんの時からもあるんですよ
だから やってる本人にとっては
なんで気分がいいのにお母ちゃんが反対するんでしょうかという態度なんですよ
もしそれが硬くなっちゃうと
全然成長が 向上がなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで素直っていうのは
本当はやりたいんだけど
私よりの先輩たちがやってはいけないんだと言うんだから
何かあるんじゃないかという
いう柔らかさ 柔らかさなんですね
で それも嫌だったらハッキリ聞けばいいんです
なんで悪いのと 私はこれやりたいんだけど
なんであんた反対するんですかと
はっきり言いなさいと
言って 相手と話し合う
喧嘩もしてみる それでやがて自分が
あ なるほど これが悪いんだと納得いくはずなんです
この納得いく性格がスバチャ
素直っていうことなんです
だから 決してバカみたく言って言われる通りにやるって意味じゃないんです
だから スッバタドゥッバチャの意味はそういう意味なんです
性格的なもので だからそれも削除できるかと
いわゆるドゥッバチャでいるということは
石のごとく もうそのまんま
まるっきりもう見込みがない人間なんです
素直でいるという人は
結構討論もするわ 話し合いもするわ
嫌なことははっきりこれは嫌ですよと言ったりもするわ
それで素直に自分を出して
それから目上の人のアドバイスをちゃんと受け取って
参考にして話し合って
ああなるほど じゃあではやりますということにならなくちゃいけない
という すごい明るい性格のことなんです
削除できません  え？ 削除できません
これですか？自教のこのスワチョってのはそういう意味だと
え？何？ 自教のスワチョー
チョって何？チョスさんのことかな
そうそうそうそう  それはあれですね
同じことです  大体同じことを言ってるわけですね
うん そこで私は皆様に聞いたのは一項目でも削除できますかと
一つでも削除しちゃうと大変なことになるんですよ
これがブッダが完全に喋ると
私が完全に喋ってるんだよと
お釈迦様は自慢していますよ
一つの証拠なんですよ
こんな風に完全に項目固めているところっていうのは
世界では存在しないんですよ
だから道徳的なところを私は日本に紹介したいし
道徳っていうのは日本でもわけもわからなくなってるでしょ
例えば日本では教育っていうのは宗教はもう置いといて道徳を教えるんだから
それは悪くはないんだけど
しかしはっきりしないんですよ
宗教を置いておいるんだけど
だらしない宗教を参考にするんですよ
ブッダの教えは参考にしない
ブッダの教えは宗教でないのにね
だからどんな学校でも
世界中学校で 人文学として
人間の生きる方法として
ブッダの教えを教えた方がいいと私は思っているんですけどね
宗教でもないし しっかり生きていられるしね
それでこの 完璧に喋るんだぞとお釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
じりじりと証拠はあるんですよ
この四十四で一つも削除できないんですよ
じゃあ一つ増やしてあげましょうと思ったっても
あれ？ということになるんですよ
先生 一個 これも今のお話にちょっと揚げ足取るわけじゃないんですけど
例えば五戒の中で あの
まあ要するに不邪淫戒っていうのはありますよね
これは多分この  まあ出家の人向けに書いているものだから
この四番の性的な関係を持たないというところに
五戒の五番目の不恩食戒みたいなのありますよね
それと相当するものはこれ見ても入ってないんじゃないかなと思うんですけど
これはあえてこの酒飲むなかれという
あまりにも俗っぽい話はしないんですよ
道徳の場合は普遍的な真理だから
例えば生肉食うなかれとかね
十二時過ぎて夜十二時過ぎたら食うなかれとかね
そんなのはもう習慣的なことであって
精神的な道徳というのに入らないんですよ
だからこれは厳密に科学的な道徳であって
心理学的に だから何かある一つの飲み物を選んで
それだけ「このお前は悪いんだから飲むなかれ」という風な
この俗的な話じゃないんです
だから取るんですよ それは
そこで不邪淫じゃなくて不邪淫でしたっけ
これはもう在家生活はどうせ家族生活ということだから
それを不邪淫にしていて
で これ出家にこの真理を目指す人
もう本物を目指すということだから
もう だから明らかにこれ出家者に語っているものであって
出家者の中でもこの禅定まで作っている仙人たちを馬鹿にして喋っているものだから
この信じられなかったレベルが高いんですよ
そういうところもちょっとちょっとありますけどね
だから 例えばお腹いっぱい食うなかれとかね
そんなのは言わないんですよ
それはもう当たり前のことなんですけど
でもたまたまお腹いっぱい食べたっても死にはせんしね
地獄に落ちないしね 例えば生肉は品が悪いんだから食いなかれと言っても
もしかすると植えて植えているところでね
もう食べたっても別にどうったことはないし
だからそういうこの その環境に応じるものっていうのは使わないんですね
あくまでも普遍的  普遍的な真理そのものっていうことで
ですよ このヤマグチではこのこのずーっと説明してましたけどね
これは見てくださいと
きちんとこれ取ってるんだよと
だからあんた方は「じゃあ酒飲んでもいいや」と思うでしょうとかね
よくからかっていろいろ
一項目ずつ挙げて説明して
結果的にこうだよってことをご説明なさって
この四十何  テキスト作りたかったんだからね
もうかなり あの 厳しくやっちゃったんです
うん それでこの話に戻りますけど
この本当はこの四十四項目の中で一つも削除できない
この四十四項目っていうのは
我々社会人としてどのように生きているかということではないんです
社会論でもないんです
これは エゴを破る論なんです
いわゆる悟り論なんですよ
だから悟る 解脱するための
あの 何でしたっけ 取扱説明書なんです
マニュアルですよ だから社会的なことっていうのは環境によって変わってもいいというところは入ってない
例えば出家には酒一滴も飲むなよとはありますけど
もし例えば筋肉の病気
体の何か病気が出てきて
塗る薬 として 医者がこの塗り薬を酒で溶かして塗らなくちゃあかんよと言ったらいいよと
これは一時的な病気なことだからね
しかし それでも飲むなかれと
それでまた疑問が出てきて
しかし 飲む薬にももういわゆるアルコールで合成する薬があるんですね
医者がそれしか薬がないんだよって言ったらどうしましょうかと
病気でも死にかけている
その場合は 酒の味と香りがないならば
病気の時だけ 医者がそれはもう認めている時間だけ
その量だけ使ってもいいと
だからたとえ薬であっても
日本の梅酒みたいに酒そのものだったら使えないんです
梅酒でも体にいいとか言って
あれはインチキですよ
ただ梅の梅が盾にして酒飲むために
酔うことが目的であってはいけないってことですか
だからそういうのはまあそこそこいろいろ変化
訂正が成り立ちますから
普遍的な宇宙法則としての真理には入らないんです
例えば これは別な宇宙の別な国に持っていく
別な星に持っていく そちらではもう当分というそのものも存在しないとする
酒もないでしょう その場合は
そうすると その項目が役に立たなくなっちゃうんですよ
これは火星に持っていっても通じるんです
生命の関係だからね 次に結論なんですけど
この四十四項目の一つも削除できない
人が何か選ぶと自分の判断で選ぶ
ブッダの判断ではないんですね
だから私はそんなに偉いかのかと
悟りの道を自分で決めるぞというのは
これは決められないはずなんです
だから一つ選ぼうとしても
私が言うのはあなたに選べませんよと
それでこちらがやりやすい方を選んだ方がいいんではないかとね
こっちにそれも怠けとか根性が弱いという話になっちゃうでしょ
で それも成り立たない
これは自殺するぐらいの大変なことだからね
一つ一つの そういうことだからどうするかというと
こちらの方おっしゃった通りに四十四も覚えておく
何か一つではなくて守ろうとする
それで世界でこの物事っていうのはいっぺんに来るわけじゃないんですよ
全ていっぺんに来ないんです
ある一分以内で嘘もつかない
もう悪口も言わない もう凶悪語もしない
不邪淫しない あれ成り立たないんですよ
例えばこちらで座っている間は不邪淫なんか関係ないでしょうに
もしかすると嫉妬も関係ないでしょうに
激怒も関係ないでしょうに
だからその瞬間で その瞬間で置かれている時
状況でエゴが牙を出すんですよ
その時この 「あ これはやってあかん」という気持ちです
だから四十四いっぺんに守るということではないんです
その場でその場で牙出すものを壊すと
例えば 自分がもうすごい立派にかっこよく決まって
あるグループに入ったとします
今度は私こそやと この一番何て言いますか
ベストドレッサーは  先生
何かゲームで頭がポコッと出てきたらポコッと叩くのありますね
あれ なんとか叩き モグラたたき
そのように徐々にとか
段階を経てとか そういうチャンスに
出たもの出ようとすると
そこでもう戒める  でいくと
だから自分がベストドレッサー
今日は自分がベストドレッサーになるぞと思って
そのグループに行ったところでいるんじゃないか
もっとすごく決まってる人が
そうすると それで初めて嫉妬が出てくるんですよ
そこでみんな嫉妬するんだけど
私は嫉妬しないように戒める
そこでも自分のエゴがすごく傷つくんですよ
こういうことでエゴが破れているんだから
この四十四項目も暗記して唱えるようにできているんです
先生 あともどるようですみません
項目 激怒しないようにっていうのと
怒らないようにっていうところがあるんですけれども
この戦場ぐらい作るような人は戦場をね
作るぐらいの思い出しっていうのは
激怒っていうのは無縁ではないかと思うんですけれど
そのケースだけで考えるとね
でもお釈迦様は普遍的な真理を語っているんだから
凡夫に悟りの道を教えているんです
凡人に それで禅定まで作った人々にとっては
そこら辺はもう現れて現れないだけかもしれませんよ
だからこれをどうやって守るかというと
牙が出そうになる時は出さないようにすることだから
一向に出したことがなかったら
それでもう問題ないでしょうに
一度も激怒という牙が自分には出してないんだと
自分は出したことはないんだと
例えば私は生まれてからも一度も出て遭遇しなかったことはいくついくつでいくらでもありますよ
だからといってそこを削除ということになりません
だってアブラハムチャリなんかは小さい時出家してたんだから
もう人生にまるっきり関係ないことでしょうし
ごく自然にこういう生き方しているし
それからこの何でしたっけ？邪念というのはね
子供頃から仏教を勉強してたんだからね
もう邪念っていうのはもうあったわけでもないしという
いろいろありますよ でも自分が牙を出すところはありますよ
この四十一番目とかね
二十九はあまりなかったんですけど
これから三十二とか 結構見覚えがある
そこでまあもう混乱したところはもう今最近ないんですけど
若い頃はもうしょっちゅうわけわからん状態とかね
だからこのそれぞれの人格のことで
例えば禅定を作った人がその四十四を守ろうとしたら
まあ全然出てこないものもある
だからで削除はできません
これは凡人に語ってます
だからブッダの教えは普遍的でなきゃあかんでしょうし
だからブッダ悟りの道は禅定を作っている仙人に限ると言ったら
それでおかしいでしょう
これは火星にいる火星人であろうが
土星にいる土星人であろうが
誰にでもできるものでなければいけませんね
だからもう変えるものも
あるものは何でもある
それで問題は 今度はそれじゃないんだよ
出すべき問題は 私から考えると
怒りと激怒っていうのは似てるんじゃないんですかと
なんで二つに分けたんですかと
ダブってるんではないかっていうことなんです
これがダブってないんですよ
しょっちゅう もうもうもうもうと怒って
もう文句ばっかり言って機嫌が悪い人もいる
それは怒りなんです いつでもまあちょっと機嫌が悪いとかね
しかし ずーっと落ち着いて穏やかにいる人も
たまたまはもうキレちゃうと
もうキレたというところがありますよ
大体四六時中機嫌が悪くて
みんなにあれダメ これダメ
何やってるんですか？そうやってしょっちゅう言ってる場合はあまり発作は起こりません
すーっと穏やかでいる場合は
突然もう怒りが起こる
それは発作ですよ それが激怒っていうことなんです
だから自分がどちらに当てはまるかっていうことで
自分がどちらで牙を出すかっていうところで気をつければいいんです
普段はいつでもニコニコで怒ることは全くない人は
あまり自分に甘えてはいけないんですよ
悟ってないんだから どこかでその環境の中でパッともう激怒という牙が出す可能性あります
そこで戒めるんです だからこの
これマニュアルだからこれ持っていて
その場でその場で当てはめるだけのことだから
四十四 覚えておかなきゃ困るんです
そこでもう一つ ケチつけるかもしれませんだけど
なんで皆様方一つかいくつか選んだ方がいいかと思ったんですかというと
これはこの宗教的な態度なんですよ
僕はすごく嫌だと思う
嫌う性格は全然直ってないんです
何か決めて じゃあこれやるぞという
では南無妙法蓮華経一日三回やりましょうとかね
こうやって何かに決めるということにして
人生ってのはそういう決められません
人生っていうのは その場でその場であることですよ
面白いものに出会ったら笑っちゃうし
面白くないものに出会っちゃうと機嫌が悪いし
ただそれだけ お腹が空いていると食べ物を見るともう食べたくてしょうがない
欲が出る お腹が満杯というのは面白くない
これ誰か片付けてくれないかというふうな気持ちになる
だから人間の人格っていうのは
性格っていうのはその場でその場で変わるもんだから
ある何とか式なり 毎日曜日教会に行ってお祈りして賛美すればいいとかね
そういうふうな形式的な文化的なものでは把握できないんです
これはやめましょうと
儀式儀礼は もし皆様方一
二項目選んだならば 儀式儀礼になるんです
それは 知識的な 理性的な自分の自己向上ということにはなりません
あ いいですか 例えばですね
この中に 四十四 項目あって
例えば八正道っていうのが大本にあって
それにぶら下がるような形でいろんな細かい項目が分かれてるとかっていうなら
なんとなく分かりやすい気がするんですけど
こういう風に羅列して唱えられたっていうのは
なんか取り止めがないないような
これはお釈迦様の文学作品でもありますよ
だからパーリ語で読むとものすごい感動するんだからね
そうすると一から 四十四 までのこの並びっていうのは意図的にやってるんですか？ これはお釈迦様が意図的にやっているものなんです
適当じゃなくて  適当じゃないんですよ
明確に順番ですよ 例えば一番っていうのは一番やりやすいんですよ
実践しやすいんですよ
まず喧嘩するなよ このバカっていうところでしょ
そこから始めているんだからね
四十四番目何でしたっけ？私も偉そうなこと言うんでしょう
覚えてないんですけどね
四十四番目は悟りそのもの
一切のディッティが消えたところなんです
だから順番ですよ 結局は
そこでこの自分の主観にしがみつくなかれっていうことは
やっぱり俗世間ではそれなりの判断しなくちゃいけないんですよ
判断だからろくなことじゃないんだけど
やっぱりラーメン食べるか
うどん食べるかっていうことで
じゃあラーメンにするぞというね
でもしがみつくなよと
そういうことで 俗世間の我々には判断しないで生きていられませんから
私もやっぱり普通はもうずっと判断で生きてますよ
これが良くない これはもうちょっと直せとかね
この文章長すぎやとかね
全て判断ですけど しがみつくってことだけはしないんです
しちゃったらもうすぐ窮屈苦しくなるんです
例えばこの方おっしゃったような
このみんな悪い もうもうなんか毒ガスまいてるような感じ
みんな毒ガスまいてるような感じなって
私だったらね やっぱりみんな毒ガスまいてるような沙汰を出してるんだからって言ったら
これしがみつくんで ものすごい苦しいんですよ
そうしたら「どうせあんた毒ガスまいてるんだからね」ということで
そんな対決終わっちゃうんですよ
だから「私は苦しいんだよ」と 「
あんたと喋るとこちらまで嫌な気持ちになるんだぞ」という
そんなことでふざけてるんですよ
しがみつくっていうことはしない
一つの項目に縛りつけるのはどういうことかっていうのは分かりましたけれど
毎日の暮らしの中で 例えばこちらのヴィパッサナー瞑想の時でも
自分の心に生じてくるある傾向とか傾向それぞれにありますよね
そうするとそれを日常の中で
例えば怒りの感情がちょっとでも漏れてきたらそれに気づくようにしよう
全部じゃなくて 怒りのこの微かな怒りでも気づくようにしようと
ある期間そういう工夫をして生きるということはどうなんでしょうか
それは一時的には何でもいいんですよ
一時的に一時的に何でもね
しがみついてはいけないし
もう一つ このこっち関係ないんだけど
ちょっと付け加えてやり直しとしますよ
ジェームス・アレンさんの本も読んでみてください
で これはみんなこの毒ガスまいてるよとおっしゃってるでしょ
これ違うんですよ 全て自分が出すものが反射してくるだけなんですよ
全て私の心が主人であって
全て支配してるんですよ
だから自分持っている貪瞋痴に気づかない限りは
相手が怒り出してるんだよっていうことは仏教的な思考じゃないんです
自分もだから同じ出して
相手と同じやっていうのは
これはもう日本的な考え方でダメですね
みんな同じだっていうこともね
自分が怒り出すと怒りしか返ってこないんです
それで環境も変わっちゃうんですよ
住んでるマンションであろうか
周りであろうが 全て自分に対してはものすごい嫌な環境になるんです
これは自分がまいた種なんですよ
だから自分が種まいていることには気づかない限りは
この問題は解決はしない
これが真理であって 全て自分が計画立てて
自分が考えて自分が得る結果なんです
これはブッダの法華経の第一偈で
そこで始まるんです 一切は己の心のせいであるという風に
気分的にも認めたくない気分あるかもしれませんだけど
そこら辺はもう自分の気分に甘えることもできない
やっぱり悪かったのは私だよという態度にならないと
みんなではなかったと
その問題は解決しないとしないんですよ
しないと思いますではなくて
とにかく我々は人間だから
いろんな意見は作りますよ
意見作らずに生きる できない
で 苦しい状態を何とか紛らわすために
まあいろいろくだらない意見も作るね
例えばもう隣の家の人はすごい激しい怒りの人だから
何か自分気分が悪いんだぞとかね
そう言ったらなんとなくほっとするというね
みんなやってるんだからと思ったところで
自分の自己嫌悪感はなんとか和らげるとか
そういうのはまああまり正しくはないんだけど
人間っていうのはそんな中途半端な的なやり方では生きている
しかし このたまたまではなくて
しょっちゅういろんな意見作っても
何一つにもしがみつくことはないという態度は一番ありがたいんです
楽しいんですよ 喧嘩しながら笑えてるんだからね
だから私はもう大体喧嘩しながらすごい笑ってるんで
だから私は皆様と喧嘩してないんですけど
で 国へ帰ったら結構喧嘩しますよ
喧嘩するんだけど 一人も出ていかないんですね
時々喧嘩しないでニコニコとると
あら 今日はちょっとやばいと調子が悪いんじゃないかと
と逆にからかわれるぐらいなんです
なぜかというと こちらはもう喧嘩はしてるんですけど
全然しがみついてない
それには だから向こうにとっては何のことなく
ただまあおかしい話だからという感じで面白く聞いてるだけ
だからもう そうやっても
あんたなんかどうしてももう毒ばっかしばらまいてる人やと言っても
あんまりこの自分自身
この人は毒だけばらまいてる
もうビンラディンやということはないんです
私 お前はね いつでも 24時間毒ばっかしばらまいてる
他のやることないの？と態度なんですね
例えば子供なんかよく体に乗っけ乗っちゃって遊びたくなっちゃうと
もういつでもそれ相手にすることできるわけじゃないし
たまたま私はお前臭いんだからとかねって言うんですよ
どうせ子供って臭いんでしょうしね
そうすると このその子供によって臭いと言われると
もうさらに攻撃かけてくるんですね
で また他の子供はもうそう言われちゃうとちょっと下がっちゃって
もうちゃんと自分の体はしっかり
またもう綺麗に生活しようではないかということで頑張る
それは私から見れば まあもうしっかりしているんだから
それも悪くはないし 臭いだからって言ったところで
もうかなり体に乗って攻撃する場合は
それなりに追い出すしかないしね
でも決してそれはもう本気になって言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
だからと言って嘘言ってるわけでもないんです
で ですから この 44番目はこの最後の項目なんですね
だから我々も 44番目最後だから
一から 44番までいっちゃうと時間ないんですよ
もう 1項目守るためにも一生かかっちゃいますから
一生の問題だから 害を与えないということは生きる死ぬまでの話でしょうに
そればっかりしまうと
あの 43どうなるんですかね
殺生しないということも一生かかるでしょうに
だから一つの削除はできないんですよ
だから 44も守る 例えば今の私たちは自分の意見にしがみついちゃうと酷い目に遭うんですよ
だから意見があるんだけど
それにしがみつかないんだと
しがみつくことはしないという態度を取らなくちゃいけない
だから 44も守る 守られるわけない
なぜならば一遍に全部来ない
来ないんだからね 怒ることになった瞬間で常識的には怒るんですが
その常識はやらない まあ例えばもうえっと
あれ イノシシが今なんかあっちこっち生えていたりする
で そこは散歩してたところで
イノシシがずっと走ってきて攻撃かけたら
まあ常識はイノシシを殺すことなんですけど
それはやらない だから殺生することになったらやらないこと
例えば蚊が止まって刺しちゃうと
常識はもう手で叩くことでしょ
みんな殺生するんだけど
私は殺生しないんだよと
その時守ればいいんです
布団に入ってみんな殺生するんです
私は殺生するという意味じゃないんですよ
その時はみんなくだらないことを考えているんだけど
私はくだらないことを考えない
布団の中でそれ その項目なんですよ
食べる時はみんな欲を出して食べてるんだけど
私は体に燃料入れる 部品入れ替えるぐらいの気持ちで食べますと
ということだから 四十四も守られると私は思います
それもいっぺんに いっぺんに覚えておく
だから作品として暗記しやすく
パーリ語でどんどん感動的に感動だけ高めて高めて持っていってるんですよ
あの文学的なんで こちら使ってる言葉は
サンレイコから言うっていうことでも
聞くだけでも私たちすぐなんとなく心に入っちゃうんですよ
あの すみません ちょっと言葉のことなんだけど
例えば二十九というところに「試みる」という言葉がありますよね
これどういう意味ですか？ 試してみる
そういうこと  うん だから「試みる」「戒める」という
その中でも自分に気に入ってるセットだけ覚えればいいんです
セット同じですからね
例えば ある人が「やってみる」という言葉が好きかもしれません 「
ものはやってみるんだよ」と
でと その人はこういう風にやってみる
みんなは害を与えているんですけど
私は害を与えないことはやってみると
あるいは「ものは試しや」というふうに
これ気に入っている人がいれば
みんなは害を与えている
私は害を与えないことを試してみるというふうに
この単語を入れ替えるんです
主語は私ですね  うん  他人は試すわけじゃないわけね
うん 私は試す  順番として最初に戒めます
次に投身します 次に試みる
次に放逸する 次に解脱する
っていうのはこの順番でやりましょう
いい 一通りでいいんですよ
解脱で言ったっても離れるって意味ですからね
だから自分がどんな言葉気に入ってるかということで
レストランに書いて  四十四種類のお料理があって
全然それは読んだだけで食べないで出てくる時は
食べてあれはあの味 これはあの味
でなんか想像した時に
あ あの時のあの味 帰ってきました
自分が自分にとってはやりやすい
レストランの例えもうちょっと訂正するならば
四十四項目品物は来るんですけど
いっぺんに四十四も自分の前に出すわけじゃないんです
クックさんがその時に何か作って
はい これこれと それは試してみる
目の前の項目にチャレンジすればいいんです
[笑い]おそらく自分の前のテーブルにはひと皿しか置けない
四十四置けませんだからね
だからクックさんが好き勝手で何か持ってくるということで
時間になりましたので
じゃあ  はい それでは五時半になりましたので
今日はこれで経典解説を一旦終わりたいと思います
また六時半からですね
お経とヴィパッサナー瞑想の一時間半ほどの会がございますので
それまでまた休憩して一階の方にお茶など用意してありますので
おくつろぎいただければと思います
それでは最後に先生に参拝して終わりたいと思います
参拝  スリランカの大統領と首相と会談やってるでしょ
これどう思う？ あんまりわからない
政府はもう初めからもうやり方汚いんだから
もう大統領はそれ気にいるわけじゃないしね
首相は強いの？弱いの？ 最悪ですよ
わからない 私も会ったことあるんですけど
何者かわからないんですね
何も一言も喋らないし
自分の連中に大統領を侮辱する
侮辱してはいけないし
最高裁判所に対して 何て言うんですか
不信任案を国会で通してやるぞとかね
なぜかというと この最高裁判所はもう大統領の判断は全て法律的で
もうどうにもならんと
なんか解任したんでしょ
だからちゃんと大臣としての秘密もう汚いことを喋って
もうもう God bless アメリカ
だからまあこれは科学者にしてもね
みんなそう言われてハマって
そこ世間でもう頑張ってますよ
別にまあ一応 だから面白くハマるということがもう統一素なんですね
だからそれが面白いんですよ
だからすごい危険なんですよ
もうもう病みつきになるんだから
人殺しちゃうと面白くなっても病みつきになる
恐ろしいことを研究開発すると
もうものすごく病みつきになっちゃう
次どうなるんでしょうか？とかね
こうすればどうなるんでしょうか？と
もう次から次へと 何でもやっちゃうってことになる
だからもう本当に管理不可能
例えば遺伝子研究やら何にしても
やっぱり面白いでしょう
どうなるんでしょうかね
これとこれといじれば
とかね 気持ちは私も分かりますよ
しかし それでも存在もしないウイルスやら何々から出てきたらどうしますかと
だから私はすごく怪しげに思ってますよ
もうもうこの香港とここら辺でね
もう流行っているあの肺炎のウイルスも
薬も何もないもの 突然現れて
すごい怪しいと思いますよ
ウイルスの開発の研究のある人が私に会って話したことはありますよ
若手の科学研究者なんですね
アメリカ人で で 聞いて
あんた何 何やってる人？で
自分はちゃんと海軍の人ですと
海軍だったらこれ何やってるんですか？そしたら実は私はこういうこういう研究をしていると
なんか分からない 私見たらすぐすぐ友達になるんだからね
もういろいろいろいろ話してるんだけど
私もすごい丁寧に探っているんですけど
こういう人々をやっていることは厳密に秘密なんですけど
何やってるんでしょうかねと
それは言わなかったんですけどね
本人がやってることは私は顔を見て隠すこともできないと
だから結構言ってはくれるんだけど
だからなんであんた熱帯にって
もういろいろと聞いたんですよ
聞いても適切な返事は出てこなかったんですけどね
熱帯にある細菌について
そんなにも  言っても質問した私も意味がないしね
まあ研究はどんなものにしてもやるもんですからね
で まあだから結構前の話でね
だから突然もう未だかつてない
素人は知らないっていうものは現れるはずない
自然の中でも人工的に作らないと
だから世の中っていうのもおかしいしね
大量破壊兵器っていうのは良くないではなくて
あの人を持つのも良くないと
ということは 大量破壊兵器が良くないっていう話ではないんですね
原子爆弾が良くないということは全く認めない
あの人が持つのは良くない
向こうの原子爆弾は良くないと
原子爆弾を作ったのはその思考良くないんだと
だから同じ罪だとどちらでも
原子爆弾をアメリカが持っててっていうのは
もうそのいくつかの国々持っていて
だから最初に開発した時でも
激しい怒り 憎しみで開発したでしょうに
だから思考が汚れてるでしょうに
ただ親分で凶暴で権力を持ってるんだから
使う必要はない しかし使っちゃったでしょ
それで使った経験がある人々はみんなにもジジイ言ったりするし
使ったこと一回もないソ連は全部解除しましょうと言うと
これはもうとんでもない話だと
ソ連が世界の平和を壊すぞとか
もうプーチンさんには悪口言うし
まあいろいろ だから人間の思考ってそんなもんで
思考自体っていうのはね
だから原子爆弾が悪いっていうことは言わないし
原子爆弾を作る思考悪いっていうのは
これは仏教だけしか言わないこと
それは言わなくていいんですから
そこまでわかるわけないんだからね
で もっと変にあの人持つのは良くない
化学兵器もあの人持つのは良くない
で そういうテロたちがなんで化学兵器を持ってるかというと
自分たちが持ってるんだからその研究でしょ
砂漠の中で洞窟の中で化学生物兵器作れますかね
サリンやら VXガスやらそういうのはすごい優れてるところで作るんであって
そこを作るんだからもう作れるんであって
だから結局原因は自分にあるんですよ
でも間違いは向こうにあるとかね
それで互いに殺し合い
殺し合いでのきりがない
で どんな科学研究でもそういうものでね
例えば今 薬の開発 遺伝の開発っていろいろあるでしょ
このあの なんて言いますか
リセプターとかなんとかって DNA の一部一部切ったりするでしょ
あれでいろんな病気を治せるんですけど
自分たちが特許を取っちゃって
誰にもあげませんと大量のお金くれと
それだったら 例えば遺伝子研究で癌が治せるとかね
いろんなもの 今まで治らないことっていうのはたくさん治るけど
それこそ人間のために役に立つことだから
素晴らしいことで もしそれは邪思惟ではなくて
正思惟であったならば慈しみでしょ
平和でしょ 思考は だから慈しみのためにやる
平和のためにやると言っちゃうと
やるとみんなの役に立ちますよ
でもそうじゃないでしょ
欲のために 研究に能力ない人々を抹殺するためにやってるんだから
[背景音楽]日本もすごいケチでしょ
研究のお金出さないんだから
能力あるのに 科学的なテクニック
ノウハウもあるのに もう立地ももういいところで
それでアメリカはもういっぱいお金出しても研究する
それでこちら全部買わなくちゃいけない
こちらで DNA の研究したければ
あのデータファイルをものすごい大量のお金払って買わなくちゃ
買ったっても条件付きで研究のみとかね
一回限りと 二番目の研究所に移してはいけませんとかね
だからここの研究所で研究して
もうちょっと研究続けてやるぞと言って
これ持って行っちゃう
また禁止なんですね そういうものまであって
こんなのはもう邪情で決まってるでしょうに
世界がそういうことで不幸になるってこと決まってるでしょうに
世界を不幸にしたのは科学者でしょうに
はっきり言えば 科学さえなければ
みんな普通に畑仕事してね
すごくのんびりと生きてるのに
こうコレステロールもないわ
高血圧もないわ 睡眠不足もないわ
何もないでしょうに がんもないわ
全て作ったのは科学者でしょうに
今 睡眠不足でありがたい薬を作ってくれるんではないかと
威張ったってもあなたでしょ
病気作ったのはと 高血圧下げる素晴らしい薬
高血圧作ったのは誰ですかね
人間の細胞 がん細胞になるまでおかしくしたのは誰ですかね
だからもう科学者いなければ世界も平和ですよ
だから仏教は全部捨てろと
全部捨てた方が楽やと
私たちは全て捨てているんです
捨てるほどそれ楽なんです
だから笑いながら国会の中継も見られるし
もうこのバカたち何言ってるかといって笑いながらもうテレビの戦争の報道を見ていられるし
それ見ながらもうやっぱり徹夜した研究をちょっとそういうものも作られるし
とにかく時間になりましたので
ではここで終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
乾杯